the first reactions to james gunn's
suicide squad are finally live
though the film was officially set to
premiere on august 6th on both hbo max
and in theaters several critics have had
the privilege of seeing it early and
their reactions are getting fans even
more excited
the movie follows a team of
supervillains who were recruited to join
the mysterious task force
x for a super dangerous mission to
defeat monsters and enemies on the
fictional island of corto maltese
fans of the original suicide squad will
enjoy seeing some of their favorite
characters return for the newest
iteration
including harley quinn rick flagg
captain boomerang and amanda waller this
rendition will also feature several new
characters such as bloodsport peacemaker
blackguard and king shark
i'm not joining your suicide squad we'll
see
excitement for the suicide squad is only
grown with every new trailer drop and
leaked photo from the set
as the premiere date quickly approaches
fans are eager for updates on the
upcoming film
and the first reviews are sure to get
audiences pumped though the original
suicide squad received lackluster
reviews it looks like the james gun led
version is everything critics could have
hoped for
stephen weintraub of collider tweeted
absolutely love the suicide squad the
movie is super violent extremely funny
and a huge home run for james gunn in dc
tons of surprises and things i wasn't
expecting just a great movie
umberto gonzalez of the rap also had
positive things to say about the film
tweeting the suicide squad is
absolutely buck wild i enjoyed the hell
out of it james gunn has easily made
dc's most enjoyable movie to date
visually stunning action-packed and full
of swagger one of the criticisms of
2016's suicide squad was that fans felt
it could have gone further with the
action violence and overall bill and his
content
kirsten acuna of insider praised gunn's
direction with a tweet that said
the suicide squad is probably the
wildest wackiest bloodiest comic book
movie i've ever seen
very clear they let james gunn run wild
and not hold back
definitely gives harley one of her best
scenes period the suicide squad has its
fair share of doubters
nonetheless even admitted skeptics
conceded that the film surpassed their
expectations carol warner of people
tweeted
so this skeptic loved the suicide squad
it is balls to the wall
bonkers in very entertaining ways i.e if
you're wondering whether james gunn and
that super rad cast would truly go there
with the material and the art rating
indeed they do ian sandwell of digital
spy also tweeted a message to naysayers
writing
any doubts you might have over the
suicide squad will vanish after the
outrageous opening
it's a violent hilarious and
unpredictable blockbuster and everyone
will have their own favorite from the
terrific cast
it's just so entertaining that you'll
want to see it again instantly
film critic drew taylor echoed
sandwell's comment writing
james gunn's suicide squad is gloriously
insane and so so fun
after watching it you'll think you might
have dreamed it everyone is excellent
and deeply committed to the material and
its singular mood and wild ass aesthetic
can't wait to ride this roller coaster
again the suicide squad is getting an
overwhelming amount of praise for its
violent material along with its humor
heart and stunning visual effects critic
brandon davis enthusiasm for the suicide
squad was obvious from his tweet
the suicide squad is absolutely insane
violent as hell
raunchy unforgiving james gunn is fully
unleashed it's sometimes overwhelming it
has moments of heart humor action
emotion
all of it relentless there's nothing
like it damn
eric davis of rotten tomatoes also noted
the stunning visuals of the suicide
squad tweeting that he
had the best time watching the suicide
squad it is a swing for the fences kind
of comic book movie and i love that
it's big bold and visually stunning you
will see james gunn's horror roots
splattered all over this thing it's
violent but hilarious
angry but also very sweet the suicide
squad hits hbo max in theaters on august
6th so prepare yourself for some epic
butt kicking
killer cinematography and james gunn's
signature sense of humor and style
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the latest dc movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one